je m'appelle pauline balthazar cab your
je suis artiste de rue et je fais partie
de la compagnie alors la compagnie oui
ça s'écrit comme ça se prononce et non
au téléphone c'est vraiment pas pratique
est mon vrai travail dans la vie c'est
d'être une super héroïne
alors vous vous demandez pourquoi je
craque mon identité secrète en plein
tedx et mon super pouvoirs par la même
occasion qui est la magie et bien c'est
tout simplement parce que là devant vous
je vais réaliser quelque chose qui n'a
encore jamais été fait pendant 1 tedx je
vais réaliser un tour extraordinaire
je vais sauver le monde en direct hier
mais alors sauver le monde ça va me
demander un petit peu plus que mon super
pouvoirs à moi ça me demandait un petit
coup de main donc je vais avoir besoin
de vos supers pouvoirs à vous et oui et
il va nous falloir pas mal d'énergie
pour sauver le monde parce que là il ya
du boulot
donc je vais vous proposer la de se
réveiller un petit peu on va se refaire
un petit tour de chauffe faire ça à
l'américaine parce qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut alors tedx saint brieuc est ce que
vous êtes là tedx saint brieuc est ce
que vous êtes chaud teddy saint brieuc
est ce que vous êtes prêts à sauver le
monde
ouais génial alors là on va commencer à
pouvoir faire quelque chose donc est-ce
que vous avez tous la petite enveloppe
qu'on vous a offert génial donc alors ça
c'est notre petit cadeau pour vous
souhaiter la bienvenue dans le super
monde des super héros
donc vous allez maintenant pouvoir
ouvrir cette enveloppe et y découvrir un
superbe masque qu'on a réalisé avec les
super pouvoirs de loisirs créatifs de
mes collègues de tmx
donc comme vous le voyez ces faits en
sac poubelle et c'est voulu
oui en fait c'est pour bien montrer
qu'on peut sauver le monde avec
n'importe quoi qui peut traîner dans les
placards inutile de passer l'après midi
à faire du shopping pour ça et donc à
bas je vois que vous m'avez précédé moi
je vais vous proposer de jouer un petit
peu on va jouer si vous le voulez bien à
jacques a dit ça vous va est ce que tout
le monde se souvient des règles ok bon
bah je vais faire un catch up là pour
tout le monde alors les règles de jacadi
sais si je dis alors jacadi fait quelque
chose on fait le truc
si je dis fait ceux-ci ont fait pas on
va on va s'entraîner jacadi lever les
bras
ouais baisser les bras a alors jacadi
lever les bras au quai jacques hétu
baisser les bras donc jacques a dit
mettez les masques je suis désolé je
peux pas le mettre avec vous parce que
je suis équipé d'un système
d'amplification révolutionnaire qui me
permet pas la chose mais j'aurais bien
aimé à vous êtes super vous avez l'air
super mystérieuse super ténébreux c'est
génial alors jacques a dit loew et vous
ah bah là ça commence à ressembler une
belle armée de super héros là là le
monde il est sauvé presque direct alors
tout le monde est équipé jacadi bomber
le torse
jacadi sentez vous fier sentez-vous
puissant jacques a dit mettez les poings
sur les hanches
regardez votre petit bidon annoncera t
on ne sauve pas le monde avec des
complexes je suis désolé enfin pour les
regardons en tout cas alors jacadi
sentez-vous fort jacadi sentez que vous
avez déjà sauvé le monde avec votre
colle en rouge non monsieur on s'envole
pas maintenant s'il vous plaît revenez
jacadi fermer les yeux levés au la tête
sentez vous vous envolez sentez-vous
grand sentez-vous très fort jacques a
dit vous êtes des super héros et
maintenant jacques a dit ouvrez les yeux
regardez votre voisin et sauver le monde
voilà jacques a dit vous pouvez vous
rasseoir
merci
donc merci d'avoir mis votre super
pouvoirs de joueurs à contribution si
jamais quelqu'un avait une mission super
héroïque
merci de vous éclipsé discrètement on va
éviter les allers et venues un paper
intempestifs
ce serait pas mal d'autres non d'accord
est ce que vous sentez bien vraiment
parce que ok bon bah c'est normal en
fait c'est super c'est même super normal
en fait c'est tellement normal que ces
scientifiques
votre état d'esprit influence votre
posture vous voyez bien dans quelle
position vous tenez quand vous allez au
travail le lundi matin vous sautillez
partout fins et c'est génial
et en fait il est prouvé aussi désormais
que votre état d'esprit influence
également votre posture et les travaux
d'amis que d'y publier en 2010 ont
permis de prouver que la posture de
superwoman celle qu'on vient là de faire
tous ensemble
elle permet d'augmenter le taux
d'hormones liés à la confiance en soi de
95% en moins de deux minutes juste
incroyable donc la prochaine fois que
vous sentez que vous avez un super
vilain morale qui vous tombe dessus
redressez vous un tiens toi droit comme
dirait ta grand mère
et puis tu verras que c'est quand même
beaucoup plus simple de sauver le monde
quand on a la patate alors rentrons un
petit peu dans le vif du sujet parlant
de super pouvoirs alors la plupart des
super héros ont tendance à dire oui mais
non mais moins tu sais je n'ai pas de
super pouvoirs et tout ça alors je suis
désolé de vous contredire mais vous
n'êtes pas si spécial que vous n'avez
pas de superpouvoirs
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
d'ailleurs c'est là que ça se passe
benjamin parker disait spider man au
grand pouvoir
les grandes responsabilités ma
grand-mère à moi disait arrête de fuir
ses responsabilités autrement dit
benjamin par coeur et ma grand mère sont
d'accord pour dire arrête de fierté
grand pouvoir
la militante féministe alice walker elle
disait la façon la plus courante qu'ont
les gens de renoncer à leur pouvoir et
de prétendre qu'ils n'en n'ont pas et
oui entre benjamin barker alice walker
et mamie je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord pour se dire qu'on tombent les
masques
qu'on arrête de se mentir et qu'on
assume nos supers pouvoirs
donc votre super pouvoirs autant vous le
dire tout de suite il se cache le plus
souvent derrière un truc un peu nul des
fois un truc tellement nulle qu'en
réalité c'est même pas votre super
pouvoirs
c'est votre super handicap est derrière
ce super handicap se cache le super
pouvoir c'est à dire c'est ce truc que
vous avez développé pour pour modifier
votre rapport au monde pour le soigner
par exemple vous étiez super chétif
quand vous étiez petit et vous êtes
devenu super haltérophiles and ou alors
vous étiez super timide et vous êtes
devenu super marrant pour pouvoir
pallier à ça dans l'exemple des
super-pouvoirs un peu nul
j'ai envie de vous parler d'un de mes
collègues de la compagnie solène qui à
sa grande époque avait la capacité
phénoménale de retrouver du premier coup
les petites culottes de ses conquêtes au
fond de son lit
ah bah ouais bah avec ça il sauvait pas
grand chose à part la pudeur de ces
jeunes femmes
cependant il avait tendance à dire aussi
que le super pouvoirs des héros réside
dans leur slip
autrement dit si on fait le lien solène
était capable de retrouver le super
pouvoir des gens au fond de son lit du
premier coup et avec ça on peut sauver
le monde donc solène est devenu notre
découvreur de superpouvoirs en chef et
nous on y croyait et c'est la confiance
dans son pouvoir qui donnait du pouvoir
à son pouvoir
donc en fait autant assumer vos trucs
bizarres autant assumer tous ces trucs
qui font de vous ce mec un peu floue et
vous demande et surtout comment vous
allez sauver le monde avec ça finalement
c'est pas la nature de votre super
pouvoirs qui est importante c'est la
façon dont vous l'employez la soeur
starhawk disait pour retrouver son
pouvoir il suffit de trouver ce à quoi
on renonce et de cesser d'y renoncer
dans l'enfance on renonce énormément
c'est une très longue rééducation pour
rentrer dans un cadre étriqué le réel et
devenir un vrai grand comme il faut
alors peut-être que si vous cherchez
votre super pouvoirs il suffirait de
vous souvenir de comment vous gériez le
monde à l'époque où vous étiez encore
petit de vous rappeler comment vous avez
modifié vos réalités pour vous permettre
d'évoluer là dedans
peut-être que vous aviez un copain
imaginaire qui pour nous n'étaient pas
du tout imaginaire bien entendu il y
avait sûrement des monstres dans votre
placard vous étiez peut-être déjà un
super héros vous naviguiez en tout cas
d'une réalité à l'autre vous jouiez à
pour dire qu' il y avait personne pour
rien trouvé à redire à ça parce que vous
étiez un gamin et la basse
quand tu es un gosse tu fais ce que tu
veux t'en a rien à faire de la réalité
des grands parce qu'en fait les émotions
qui nous traversent à ce moment là sont
aussi réelles et puissante que si le jeu
lui-même l'était moi quand j'étais petit
j'allais très souvent en garderie dans
la classe de maternelle de mon papa et
j'ai pu expérimenter la puissance de ma
toute première phrase complète qui était
donne papa a dit donne alors autant vous
dire que ja séné cette phrase là sans
pitié à tous mes petits camarades de
classe que du fait de plus de ma gorge
glorieuse lignée les gamins me donner
leurs jouets comme ça enfin j'étais la
reine de la récré je savais que j'étais
une magicienne
sauf que les autres avaient tendance à
dire que j'étais plutôt une quatre issus
et autant vous dire que j'ai dû renoncer
à ce à cette première expérience
manipulatoire de l'univers et puis bah
sinon j'aurais fini au coin quoi donc
voila mais moi au fond je savais que
j'étais pas une capricieuse que c'était
pas un super handicap pour moi c'était
de la magie gt gt puissant que je
pouvais obtenir absolument tout ce que
je voulais et là je l'utilisé en mode
magie noire pour obtenir des choses pour
moi dans mon propre intérêt mais rien ne
dit que si j'avais didonne papa a dit
donne la paix dans le monde
on l'aurait sûrement apporter sur un
plateau d'or et d'art
jean est en fait rien de prouvé le
contraire et j'avais même d'autant plus
la validation de ce pouvoir là puisque
les gamins de donner leurs jouets c'est
que j'avais gagné
c'est comme ça que moi je me racontais
le monde
et pourtant quand on a joué au super
héros avec les copains l'année dernière
eh ben j'ai passé un temps fou à à dire
que j'étais nul à râler à bouder à dire
que ce jeu était vraiment pourri et puis
au bout d'un moment force est de
constater que les autres trouver leurs
super pouvoirs et qu'il était temps que
moi j'arrête de râler et de bouder et de
dire que c'était pourri comme jeu alors
du coup j'ai essayé de me rappeler de ce
à quoi je jouais pendant ce temps là et
moi je jouais à à jouer je jouais à
faire du far breton pour nous
réconcilier canton s'était fâché je
jouais à organiser une chasse aux oeufs
de pâques en pleine réunion parce que
franchement on s'ennuyait sec je jouais
à organiser la chenille dans les rues de
saint-brieuc parce qu'à ce moment là on
avait bien besoin d'une bonne séance de
transe collective et je jouais a montré
des photos de chatons rigolo à mes
copains quand il était triste ou qu'ils
étaient fatigués ou un petit peu déprimé
en fait je jouais à changer l'état
d'esprit des gens par des gestes par des
actions et en fait ça c'était de la
magie donc avec ça je me suis dit pareil
je peux sauver le monde
alors du coup je me suis prise très au
sérieux dans cette histoire de magie
j'ai joué le jeu à fond je me suis mise
à relire mon propre monde et les objets
qui m'entouraient mont rouge à lèvres
est devenue une peinture de guerre non
un vrai objets rituels d'un tatouage
j'ai fait un acte magique censée me
protéger et me rendre la source de mon
pouvoir et je montrais mes photos de
chatons comme autant de bonnes vieilles
baguette magique et ce nouveau récit là
sur ma vie il me redonnait du pouvoir il
me redonner une capacité à agir
et alors j'ai compris que la magie était
dans des choses simples qu'il ne
nécessitait pas de bave de crapaud ou
d'un sorcier avec une grosse verrue
dégueulasse sur le coin du nez pour
faire de la magie qu'il suffisait de
poser des jets
avec une intention derrière et
d'attendre que la magie arrive je me
suis rendu compte que la magie
finalement on ne pouvait pas la faire
vraiment qu'on pouvait simplement posé
les conditions pour lui permettre
d'arriver je me suis rendu compte que le
super héros finalement n'était qu'un
sorcier un peu plus mainstream que les
autres avec un super collants si votre
far breton a la capacité de réconcilier
les gens et que vous sentez que vous
pouvez sauver le monde avec ça qu'est ce
qui vous empêche d'envoyer un million de
far breton sur les zones de conflits
internationaux
je suis très sérieuse qu est ce qui vous
en empêche
parlez-en autour de vous et vous verrez
bien qu'il y aura toujours un autre type
bizarre pour dire mais oui génial bien
sûr ça va marcher à fond et là il y aura
un gars qui va vous amener son super
pouvoir de savoir faire une une pâte à
gâteau comme ça sont grumeaux et il y
aura un autre super héros qui vous
apportera la recette parfaite du far
breton
et puis un autre super héros pour vous
amener pour vous amener à communiquer
partout dans le monde sur votre far
breton de la paix et vous verrez bien et
au bout d'un moment peut-être que votre
de votre initiative il naître un
mouvement collectif et la magie pour
arriver mais il y aura toujours
quelqu'un et ça je vous le promets pour
jouer avec vous il y aura aussi toujours
des gens qui n'aimeront pas le far
breton des gens pour dire qu'on ne sauve
pas le monde avec un gâteau ou des gens
pour vous prendre pour un super méchant
parce que votre far breton et bahnini
vegan ni bio il y aura toujours des gens
qui ne croiront pas à votre magie des
gens qui vous feront douter de ce que
vous avez à faire
mais vous êtes responsable de votre
magie vous êtes responsable de votre
super pouvoir maintenant qu'il est
dévoilé vous ne pouvez plus le laisser
vous êtes responsable de vos actes
magique et de leurs conséquences
votre plus grande responsabilité et là
dans votre capacité à faire envers et
malgré tout ce que vous avez à faire est
en prendre soin jamais batman ne se
laissera dire que franchement sauver
gotham city
c'est chaud gros qu on ferait mieux
d'aller boire une bière jamais batman ne
se massera dire ça et vous vous savez ce
que vous avez à faire
vous l'avez toujours su
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses mains
lâcher
à
[Musique]
a sonné
dieu